like how many staff members do you have
to like help you just function with the
stuff that you do i have 15 full-time
employees right now holy [ __ ] damn who i
hire
[ __ ] you that's this is and you're just
one guy i'm just a dick us three you i
think you hire more people right now
than we do yeah
yeah all of us combined yeah yeah
it's it's it's helpful
because what you find out is like okay
you do need a huge team to do all this
and it's much better if it's in-house as
opposed to reaching out to someone else
to do it all right because then there's
like onboarding and they might not do it
right and you can't really get mad at
them because you know they're just doing
that they're doing their job i think i
think we figured out how much work and
effort it takes to plan like a live show
when we did like our 24-hour charity
stream yeah and even that was like i
think like pretty simple compared to
some of the stuff you guys are doing
well that took like months and months of
planning
um and like yeah even still it was like
[ __ ] hard to pull off as well
yeah yeah like the schedule crumbled by
the second half because we're all just
so [ __ ] dead yeah because we plan to
do like six or seven other things in the
second half and we're all just like oh
let's just read donations for the next
two hours i remember watching and it was
like a period where you all looked like
you had taken ketamine and you're
reading donations and you're just in a
daze like
connor you were just like thank you then
and like people were talking next to you
and you i don't even think you were in
it i was completely dead i don't know
why it's such a good event though yeah
it was really fun yeah we really want to
do another one yeah i mean i i like the
i like the idea of doing the other one
but i remember the last seven to eight
hours of that stream and i just i just
like
we need we need some way to like rotate
out or something guys
that was that was hard just do like
eight eight eight or something or just
have one person sleep while the other
person it's like when old military
people would be on guard and then yeah
the other people rest then you swap yeah
i think we made the mistake of drinking
when chris came on and then like like
like after we stopped drinking when he
came off that's when it like truly hit
like that's when like uh
with like cider and he's like boys
i was like oh
[ __ ]
not gonna say no
it came all the way i mean
let's get that it was good yeah it
turned out really well yeah yeah yeah
man i always wondered why you don't
stream on youtube i think i talked to
you about that you guys
because you guys are so big on youtube
like you're the biggest podcast i feel
like in terms of floor
or one of the on youtube and i was like
oh it makes so much sense to just stream
on youtube you'd probably get a bunch of
viewers but then you're like everyone go
to twitch yeah i don't know i don't know
why we decided to go for twitch instead
of youtube maybe one day they can sign
us right yeah
this is what this is like
just like switch days on top
because when you're like where do i live
stream you're like twitch
yeah i don't know i mean we we didn't
really have much plans
regarding the live streaming it was kind
of like an experiment the experiment
turned out really really [ __ ] well
and then we are kind of like figuring
things out as we go along because i
think always our youtube is our main
priority and then the the after dark
twitch streams were just
things that we wanted to do on the sides
um and yeah and twitch is pretty helpful
they've given us some more incentives to
stream on their platform as well which
is good which youtube hasn't so it's
kind of like whatever platform is like
hey we'll we'll we'll help you we'll
give you reasons you're like a kid and
it's like just a old truck waving candy
in front of you yeah and you're like yes
yeah well i mean like i mean because the
platforms do the same thing really yeah
i mean
which everyone is willing to help you
out more and give you more tools to do
what you need to do
we just went for the truck that had more
candy yeah there's a lot of candy in
there
how's the changeover been from let's
twitch to youtube oh
terrible
yeah i think um
i had the foresight to ask one of uh
like the people i hire he's a developer
his name's otto to make an extension
that would make the the transition much
more seamless and that's been a godsend
because i don't know if you've ever been
in a youtube chat
it's miserable yeah the delay is
terrible yeah the messages flow like
water and you can barely read them you
feel like you're going crazy yeah yeah
uh and everyone is just like a youtube
normie so they're all just kind of not
fun to talk to how haven't they fixed
that it seems so simple to fix because
they have like a
million employees and are bloated in our
scene like susan
i can be but then she'll be like yeah
and they'll do like eight months of
analysis and research and then figure
out how to fix it and then decide if
they want to fix it yeah they're just
slow and i think they will it'll just be
like in two years right i realized
yesterday after going on the yard right
that susan had to go up those ladders
yeah you made susan go up like ladders
together
i did [ __ ] dude susan
i interviewed her on the yard saying
yeah yeah susan would just be the uh
to get to my podcast room uh we
basically changed a closet into just
like a ladder room and it's kind of like
a fireman ladder it's literally a
vertical ladder that's your closet it
was a it was it was a closet let me just
change it into that because the only
other way to get in is like it's one of
those attic doors that you need to pull
down with a string right but it goes
into my roommate's aiden's room and it
like it leaves dust everywhere so we
don't like to use it so i offer twos in
that and it's like more you know uh
diagonal and she was like no i want to
go up the ladder
and i was like all right bet
no help though
how did that happen
susan thing yeah i
i tweeted at her jokingly while doing
the podcast yeah and i'll because they
were like oh they're like do you talk to
susan i'm like yeah i'm close to that
i'm tired with her so i just as a meme i
was like come on my podcast and then she
talked to like the people who hired me
to youtube and she's like man i'm down
like let's see if we can set it up and
then she actually came and she was super
nice you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i was
like i was nervous joking
well okay
what's [ __ ] okay so
we started joking before she was gonna
come on cause she knew we knew she was
coming on about about susan and we made
some we make some not so savory jokes
yeah you know uh we made some jokes
about about dogs who run a clinic and in
the clinic they are scientists and they
test by having sex with adult women
anyways the point of this joke
i don't know where it spawned connor it
just happened it happened okay and the
joke devolved to a point because we kept
running with it and no one wanted to end
it we were talking about a doberman
named bruce having sex with susan and
we're all laughing about this
and then susan
reaches out to my partner manager and
she's like what's a good episode of the
yard to listen to
and he's like
he listens he's like i'll give you one
and she's like no i want to listen to
the most recent one
and he's like no you don't
she's like no i really do
and so i i think she listened to it and
i think she's so aware of the content
that happens yeah that she was cool with
it she was like oh i get it like you're
just making content and you're doing
anything to make choices
yeah and she was cool with it but i was
like that was the most nervous i was
it's like when she came and i was like
i'm gonna get yelled at
i'm sorry so what was that about dogs
i would be mortified yeah
it's like a teacher calling you into
their classroom so i saw the note that
you were passing around in the classroom
yeah missed opportunity susan could have
roasted him oh yeah yeah i know we're
good that would have been some great
great news that would have been so
amazing it would have been it would have
been
the downfall of ludwig
i watched the whole thing it was really
good you killed it yeah it went great
and i think it was i think it was good
like it made her seem like a human
because i don't think
because like i just genuinely don't
think people get to see her a lot yeah
yeah yeah and the whole science
laboratory yeah and she's and she is
yeah formed in a lab of course like all
ceos
did you have to do a lot of prep for
that episode because like whenever we
have guests on we we just do like zero
prep yes it's been eye opening like
going on like other podcasts and meeting
other creators having like [ __ ]
talking points laid out and i'm like
[ __ ] man
what are we we should probably do that
we should probably do that
we do the same thing when we have guests
uh
but with this one i had to tell them
everything i was going to do
because she has like a team yeah she's
like content person social media person
youtube person and they all hopped in a
meeting they're like what do you want to
do and i was like i want to get an nft
of homer simpson spreading his [ __ ]
and then say i bought an nft and they're
like no
i want to bring in a doberman you know
i couldn't even show the pepe uh
oh that was golden i didn't tell him
about that oh you just did it that's the
one thing i did because i told him about
everything and i was like well i really
want to catch her off guard and so then
i was like i'll show a picture of a pepe
hanging himself which maybe wasn't the
classiest idea yeah were they annoyed
about that no no the actually the only
thing because there was literally a
watch party downstairs in my living room
while i was happening and i could hear
laughter like through every part and so
i knew i was killing it when they would
laugh but there was one part where i
came down after and they were like yeah
everyone viscerally cringed and it was
when i said the word come
on
and i was like wow i'm shocked because i
showed them so much worse things i
thought
you said the word cam in what context
uh because i talked about how my
girlfriend's podcast gets demonetized
and it was just a broader intro to
demonetization and i was like well our
podcast we talk about [ __ ] and come a
lot
just to like that's what we do
and then and then
apparently they were just they were like
losing it downstairs and just devolving
into like
like among a sus picture face
yeah yeah and that was it oh my god i
can accept a frog hanging yourself but i
draw the line i shouldn't come
let's be classy
i think we're
we're in trouble as well
just had a hentai artist on recently
that was that was an interesting
conversation on their show and they were
like uh so you're you're uncircumcised
right and i'm sorry yeah i was like what
are you boy you've got to be unsuggested
yeah that is our intro question yeah
yeah this has to be an uncut couch
i believe this is all uncut wow this is
an honor
you guys should know that we've seen
each other's [ __ ] we're all good
because you're not from america oh we're
not from america they all they also they
also yeah yeah yeah yeah for some reason
that's why we don't have the
conversation because we already we've
already seen each other's dicks because
you're like onsens in japan and
everything like we're aware of each
other's circumcision circumstances
conor told me that we went rock climbing
and there's a shower and obviously like
there's curtains and dividers but after
he's like yeah just so you know like
i've seen joey's dick
they were asking like they were like i
think something came up about onsen i
was like you see each of the sticks yeah
that's what you do and they're like what
what can i ask a question yeah sure okay
i i know what he's gonna ask oh he's
fine
what are you doing would this let me
into an onsen could i cover it or is
that no you're good with that you're
going to do it you're good with that
yeah go i thought you were just about to
think about that
you're gonna be like where do i where do
i stand
thinking about starting a wiki dick you
know out of five you know what are you
doing i'm sorry for that by the way
i got the tattoo and my first fear was
now i can never go into a japanese onsen
you could also just wear if you're
really worried about it just put a
band-aid on it but isn't that like
rude no no no no
i thought it was like sacred and i would
be tainting the water with my you know
what's more tainting and if you had
blood everywhere and puss all in there
yeah i guess that's fair just put it no
one cares about a band if you're really
really worried about just put a bandaid
on yeah yeah yeah yours is small enough
where like people won't even see it in
passing anyway
the times where they like [ __ ]
themselves is if you have like a whole
sleeve or something yeah yeah yeah you
got like a couple of small ones yeah
like we've had friends who have had like
very very small tattoos come on and they
just like they put a towel over it or
you know sometimes a lot of people just
don't even care really yeah i'd be
really impressed you're kicked out for
that okay yeah yeah it has to be like a
really traditional place to be
like that yeah like no you're not also
why they're looking yeah yeah he's like
why are they look at that
yeah like damn you do leg day yeah yeah
yeah yeah because the thing with onsen
people people think that you just like
go around staring at each other's dicks
and all that stuff and it's just like no
it's just in your periphery
for 10 minutes yeah yeah yeah yeah you
acknowledge that yeah
maybe 15 if it's like a good dick
i need a good gander